well i'm pleased to say that we are now
joined by taipei's representative to the
united kingdom
uh mr shay thank you very much for being
with us this morning it's a real
pleasure to have you in the studio with
us um
the things that are happening around
your eye must be terrifying for for the
government of course and the people
there
how do you see the way that uh the
chinese army are preparing what do you
think they are preparing for well well
thank you colony this is actually indeed
a very challenging moment for for taiwan
and the ongoing chinese military drill
surrounding taiwan across taiwan strait
uh is uh is is uh is really bad
development
uh and we do condemn that it's really
alarming
and i i think uh it's actually a blatant
attempt to change the status quo across
taiwan straight by force and
unilaterally so this is very alarming
and we've seen
uh
hundreds of authorities by the pla air
force's
aircraft and their naval vessels are
crossing uh crossing the medium line in
the in the taiwan strait which is say
which is a line that separates the
military operations on both sides for
decades uh also they they've conducted
live drill live fire drills uh including
flight
uh including the missile uh political
missiles flying over taipei flying out
over taiwan
uh even drones uh include incursions
have been happening in in offshore
islands so all these are a very very
escalatory uh
behavior so we do condemn that and we
hope that the international community
can gather together uh to push back uh
this uh
this this behavior which is uh really uh
heightened the tensions of the
region infringing the sovereignty of
taiwan uh and uh and it's really
interrupt disrupting uh in some to some
to a great extent the international
trade uh shipping rules ava civil
aviation all these so it's it's alarming
so we we call the international uh
community to pay attention to this and
certainly uh we
we noticed that the g7
foreign ministers uh issued a statement
the other day uh which made it very
clear that it's a shared and steadfast
uh commitment uh of theirs to uh to uh
to maintain your peace and stability
across taiwan straight and there's a
steadfast commitment to it do you want
to see them go further do you want there
to be a nato style
protection packed in place for time work
i would certainly uh welcome that that
kind of thought and in fact
you know the medium line itself is very
very important to keep the peace and
stability uh in the taiwanese trade and
i i would certainly hope that the g7
other countries other friends can
further realize
that uh the medium line uh is if really
is really the key the defining uh
indicator of peace and stability across
taiwan straight and status quo in the
region and you say the media line has
been crossed during these yes yes
multiple times in the air and on sea
yeah and you say that this is the start
of the change of the status quo i mean
do you think this is precursor to an
actual invasion
i can't really you know for say for sure
but uh obviously this drill uh it didn't
just pop out overnight it has to be
prepared for for for some time
so
in terms of timing we we do believe
this is perfectly an orchestrated sort
of crisis uh by by china and it's being
elongated as well am i right that it's
it's going on for longer than was
expected yes it was originally announced
to go for three days and then four days
and then and then
extend it indefinitely uh but i don't
know how long it's going to last
but i do know that taiwan on our part we
will continue to
exercise
restraint caution uh and and work on our
deterrence capabilities
and also
get as much as possible the attention
the support from the international
communities and that by international
community i i think uh you know take
this instance of the case of
ukraine
uh the uh
free world's commitment free world's
solidarity over ukraine is for a noble
cause of principle
uh that a any democratic country uh is
free to make its own choices
now now it's in for taiwan i think it's
time
uh uh for a world of three worlds commit
free worlds solidarity over taiwan
over time to stand and stand firm and uh
i i think it's utterly important
for the rest of the world to understand
to know
what does that look like though so if
you if you let me push you on this
because
we we know that the americans have this
kind of ambiguity around defense your
supplied weapons from the west so you're
able to build up your military so what
does it look like for them to to promise
your democratic future what do you want
to hear what kind of words do you mean
the united states the united states the
uk well of course yes yes uh i think we
will defend ourselves that's that's for
sure uh but we do need uh uh other
support from the from from important
partners uh the united states
commitments to uh uh to uh uh the peace
and stability across town state uh is
from and we see that we've seen that
particularly in the us congress you know
it's a it's a bipartisan cross chamber
support we appreciate that we will
continue to cultivate that and but also
we need
the support uh
from other uh major countries of course
the uk i would say uh uh if the uk can
continue uh further uphold uh the the
the principle of rules-based
international order and continue to take
the take the leadership role in the g7
and other multi multilateral platforms
uh to
uh to urge
uh the peace and stability in the region
and and also continue to broaden and
strengthen the bilateral relations both
in scope in sectors uh
with taiwan uh then then i think it it's
it's the the need we the help we need uh
down the road but all in all still we we
understand perfectly it's entirely up to
ourselves defender uh to defend the
country the system we have the way of
life and the economy that we have built
over the past decades and how prepared
are you to defend yourselves and talk to
us about how the geography of the island
of taiwan gives you a a fortress of
defense anyway in the event of the
invasion that may well come from china
in the future
i think we are always
we are always
vigilant we prepared because the threat
from china it's not just overnight it's
not just last week last week or last
year it's been like that for decades
nearly 70 years
uh people like me grew up have been
growing up uh in in this kind of uh uh
uh
sort of a hemisphere that we have to be
ready all the time
uh so now uh
definitely we need to build up continue
to build up shore up our deterrence
capabilities hardware and all those and
then we are now also
looking at the possibility of
reserve
reform things like that and also there
have been a
voluntary uh
sort of a civilian defense training
among the people and these these are
good signs because basically proves that
people of taiwan are determined to
defend our sovereignty and the way our
life uh
our way of life i have a couple more
questions where you don't have end of
time i do want to try and get these
these two in
on in that in in terms of
of making sure that you have the the
relevant uh munitions to defend yourself
and also that the training is there
would you like to see more help from
britain in doing that do you know that
we've been training
yes i certainly do but not necessarily
in the sense that you were mentioning
about the efforts the uk has been put
with regard to you to to ukraine uh i i
think uh
important thing is to to boost uh the
necessary relevant uh cooperation in in
uh
in those strategic sectors
uh of course defense industry is is is
is broad
uh
and and there is definitely
opportunities for both sides to to
cooperate uh and uh i think we're pretty
much on the right track uh because uh
the uk uh we noticed that uh it's
uh it's been told it's been implementing
this still two percent indo-pacific uh
policy uh it's now looking at that part
of the world for the future interest the
united kingdom uh particularly in
developing all kinds of relations
across the board including trade you
know a lot of
cptpp and and other bilateral packs are
are information what about the the sale
uh the purchase of british made weapons
we can we do not we certainly do not
rule out that but obviously it's subject
to many many uh considerations uh and uh
of course on our part i personally i
would say i we would certainly hope that
the the uk can be forthcoming uh in in
that sense uh but then many factors are
involved are you having those
conversations now because look this is a
very very tense time as you rightly lay
out
are you having those conversations with
people in the british government now
about the sale of what personally no i
don't yeah okay i want to ask you one
more thing and it's about xi jinping we
know how important history and dates are
to uh mr xi and we know that coming up
in the autumn there is the extraordinary
people's congress where he's going to
get another term
how concerned are you that we are in
sort of the build-up to that moment to
that moment that historical moment where
he may well launch innovation as we've
seen these uh
exercises perhaps laying the groundwork
for that well the the common sense tells
us that uh uh anyone who is says
uh in powerful for too long or even uh
made to be a lifetime leader uh if it is
not a democracy uh uh
it's something else then what you see is
you know perfect example was ukraine you
know the a a a leader in a leader of an
authoritarian regime with some sort of
sense of historical mission on his
shoulder
and and then of course in the case of xi
jinping
and perhaps in the case of many chinese
communist party leaders
in the in their minds
that something
can be done to boost their own prestige
and historical position
so that's where the danger is
but with but but i think basically
this is something indeed the
international community have to pay
attention to the especially liberal
democracies have to get together
to
to ensure that
no
fancy ventures being taken uh down the
road that will ruin uh the peace and
stability in in in
in in the region absolutely right okay
i'll share a taipei's representative to
the uk i really appreciate your time
this morning so thank you so much thank
you thank you